2026년 5월 18일 월요일 미국 증시 요약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 하락 마감했습니다.
투자자들이 중동 분쟁에 향방을 예의주시하는 가운데 기술주의 약세가 발목을 잡았습니다.
여기에 고유가로 인플레이션 우려가 다시 커지면서 고금리 기조가 예상보다 길어질 수 있다는 전망이 국채의 금리를 끌어올렸고
이는 시장 전반의 부담으로 작용했습니다.
다만 장막판 트럼프 대통령이 화요일로 예정됐던 이란 공격 계획을 철회했다고 밝히면서
SNP의 지수는 낙폭을 상당 부분 만회했습니다.
트럼프 대통령은 이번 결정이 카타르, 사우디, 아랍에미리트 요청에 따른 것이라고 설명했습니다.
앞서 일요일 트럼프 대통령은 이란을 향해 신속히 행동에 나서야 한다며
그렇지 않을 경우 아무것도 남지 않을 것이라고 강력히 경고한 바 있습니다.
SNP의 지수는 0.07% 하락마감입니다.
특히 메모리 반도체 관련주의 매도세가 두드려졌는데 그 진원지는 시게이트였습니다.
시게이트 CU가 JP모건 컨퍼런스에서 신규 공장 건설에는 시간이 너무 오래 걸린다며
기술 전환을 통해 수요에 대응하겠다고 발언한 직후 주가는 약 7% 급락했습니다.
이 발언은 AI 데이터 센터용 스토리지 수요가 폭발적으로 증가하는 상황에서
업계의 공급 능력이 이를 충분히 따라가지 못할 수 있다는 우려를 증폭시켰습니다.
여기에 메모리 및 스토리지 업종 특유의 사이클이 고점에 다다른 것이 아니냐는 해석까지 더해지며
관련주 전반에 하락세가 뚜렷하게 나타났습니다.
한편 이날 상중 미국과 이란 양국은 서로의 새로운 제안이 합의를 도출하기에는 불충분하다며 거부사를 밝히기도 했습니다.
엑시오스 보도에 따르면 베아카는 이라인에 놓은 제안에 의미 있는 진전이 없다고 평가했으며
이란 역시 미국 요구사항을 수용할 수 없다는 입장을 고수했습니다.
이에 앞서 이란 언론이 미국 정부가 일시적인 제재 유예를 제안했다고 보도하면서
호르무제협을 둘러싼 대치 국면에 돌파구가 열릴 것이라는 기대감이 한때 시장에 낙관론을 불어넣기도 했습니다.
그러나 한 미국 관료를 통해 해당 보도는 사실 무근인 것으로 확인됐습니다.
나빌레노스 시잇의 루이스 나빌리에는
이란 사태가 해결될 때까지 시장의 변동성을 지속될 것이다.
NFJ Investment의 번스 맥키니는
최근 시장을 움직이는 가장 큰 변수는
호르무제협 봉쇄 우려가 유가를 끌어올리고
이것이 장기적으로 인플레이션 기대를 다시 자극할 수 있다는 불안으로 이어지면서
국채의 금리가 오르고 있다.
이처럼 금리가 높은 수준을 유지하는 환경은
기술주와 반도체 주처럼 밸리션 부담이 큰 성장주에 특히 불리하다.
제프리스의 제프리 파보자는
엔비대 실적 발표를 앞두고 주시장 약세와 높은 채권 금리가 맞물리면서
그동안 랠리를 이끌던 기술주들이 압박을 받고있다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 5월 19일 화요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 21시 연준 월러 이사
23시 미국 4월 잠정주택 판매가 예정되어 있습니다.